bien chers collègues bonjour à toutes et
à tous j'ai quelques annonces à vous
faire avant de rentrer dans le vif du
sujet première annonce le bureau de la
commission des affaires économiques qui
s'étaient réunies donc le 5 avril
dernier a décidé de créer cette nouvelle
mission d'information et vous avez
procédé à la nomination des rapports de
6 missions sur les 7 le 12 avril dernier
il nous en restait donc une il vous est
ainsi proposé de nommer pour la dernière
mission d'information relative à
l'avenir de l'industrie spatiale
européenne comme Cora porter madame
Cécile RIAC comprenez sens et Monsieur
Aurélien Lopez ligori groupe
rassemblement national je demande la
sentiment général pas d'opposition et
bien on considère que c'est donc fait
deuxième annonce je vous informe que la
Commission examinera mercredi 31 mai la
proposition de loi visant à remédier aux
déséquilibre du marché locatif en zone
tendue ce texte sera inscrit en séance
publique dans le cadre de la Semaine de
l'Assemblée nationale le 12 juin et il
vous est proposé de nommer comme cours
rapporteur madame anaïg Le Meur du
groupe Renaissance et Monsieur
ignyaki et tiani du groupe socialiste je
demande le sentiment général pas
d'opposition particulière nous
considérons donc qu'ils sont nommés
nous passons donc au coeur du sujet de
ce matin la commission des affaires
économiques examinent la présentation du
rapport d'information de Mesdames Maud
guettel et Anaïs sabatimi sur le Quick
commerce la numérisation de notre
société engendrée de nouveaux modes de
consommation et notamment le Quick
commerce qui désigne des services de
livraison express de produits de grande
consommation autrement dit l'économie de
la flemme comme certains l'appel le
toujours plus quick impose un toujours
plus proche et certains quartiers ont vu
fleurir ce que en bon français l'on
nomme des Dark Store et des Dark kitchen
avec leurs mots leur lot de nuisances
visuelle sonore et parfois olfactive
certes ce phénomène est très localisé
voire très concentré dans quelques
métropoles et même plutôt dans certains
quartiers il n'en pose pas des problèmes
il en pose des problèmes de voisinage il
soulève surtout de nombreuses questions
d'ordre économiques notamment sur la
rentabilité du modèle un éditorial du
monde publié hier craignait même que
nous députés ne soyons frustrés de voir
disparaître cette activité avant même
d'avoir pu légiférer
pour l'heure on s'est interroge encore
néanmoins sur la concurrence faite au
commerce de proximité le Quick commerce
soulève aussi des questions d'ordre
social en particulier sur le droit
applicable au livreur pour toutes ces
raisons mode Gatel a sollicité à
l'automne dernier la création d'une
mission d'information associée à Anaïs
Sabatini elle formule aujourd'hui 24
propositions pour réguler ce secteur
s'agissant plus particulièrement des
problématiques liées à l'urbanisme le
cadre réglementaire de ces implantations
vient d'être sensiblement clarifié par
un décret et un arrêté publié le 22 mars
dernier dont les dispositions entreront
en vigueur le 1er juillet et ne seront
pas rétroactives pensez-vous mesdames
les rapporteurs que ces textes
réglementaires sont de nature à mettre
fin aux problèmes d'acceptabilité que
les implantations de Dark store ont pu
rencontrer mesdames les rapporteurs vous
avez la parole
madame sébatini merci monsieur le
Président chers collègues la mission
d'information sur le Quick commerce
confié par la commission des affaires
économiques à Madame Gatel et moi-même
s'est fixé plusieurs objectifs qui sont
développés dans le rapport que nous vous
présentons aujourd'hui tout d'abord nous
avons analysé les caractéristiques de ce
secteur ainsi que le modèle d'affaires
sur lequel il repose aussi nous avons
mesuré l'impact de son développement
extrêmement rapide ainsi que les
modalités de son implantation sur les
activités commerciales préexistantes
mais aussi sur la vie sociale et
environnementale en milieu urbain nous
avons déterminé l'ensemble des
externalités négatives engendrées par
l'implantation de ces nouveaux types
d'établissements commerciaux dans les
centres-villes des métropoles françaises
enfin en tenant compte des témoignages
et des analyses de l'ensemble des
personnes auditionnées nous avons évalué
la pertinence du cadre normatif
applicable et la nécessité de faire
apparaître de nouveaux instruments de
régulation une des spécificités
rencontrées à l'occasion de nos travaux
et de nos avions connaissance de manière
concomitante à ces derniers et la
rédaction de décret qui modifierait le
classement des établissements du Quick
commerce en droit d'urbanisme un arrêté
un décret ont un effet été publ ié le 22
mars dernier s'est arrêté et se décrit
seront applicables à partir du 1er juin
juillet prochain pardon
je ne vais pas revenir sur l'ensemble
des propositions présents dans le
rapport qui vous a été communiquée mais
j'en évoqué certaines qui me semble
particulièrement significative le Quick
commerce se définit comme une activité
de vente à distance de produits de
grande consommation réalisée par voie
télématiques et qui repose sur
l'engagement d'une livraison à domicile
d'un délai très brève de l'ordre de
quelques minutes il se caractérise
également par une chaîne logistique qui
s'appuie sur des implantations situées à
proximité immédiate des lieux d'achat
landies à partir desquels opère un
service de livraison pour cette raison
il s'agit d'un phénomène urbain qui ne
concerne à l'heure actuelle et en France
que les grandes métropoles le concept de
Quick commerce regroupe différents types
d'établissements un premier lieu ce
qu'on appelle les Dark Store qui sont
des locaux destinés au stockage des
produits ainsi qu'à la préparation des
commandes passées à distance c'est dark
Store sont généralement dotés de
vitrines opaque si leur donne ce qui
leur donne leur nom et ils n'ont pas
vocation à accueillir de clientèle en
second lieu nous avons les Dark kitchen
qui d'un des locaux aveugles proposent
des services de restauration commerciale
sous forme de repas cuisinés ou à livrer
sans accueillir de clientèle elles sont
aménagées de manière identique à une
cuisine de restaurant traditionnelle
sans comprendre bien entendu la salle de
restauration pouvant accueillir le
public enfin troisième lieu nous avons
les draps piétons qui peuvent être
considérés comme étant le troisième
modèle du Quick commerce il propose aux
consommateurs de retirer leurs courses
commander sur internet à des comptoirs
physiques auprès de casier connecté et
réfrigérée ils peuvent être adossa des
supermarchés préexistants ou fonctionner
de manière autonome en général ce ne
sont que des espaces de retrait en effet
le stockage des produits et la
préparation des commandes s'effectue
dans des entrepôts généralement séparé
sur le plan géographique le Quick
commerce est un phénomène
particulièrement récent en France son
développement coïncide avec la crise
sanitaire période marquée par des
restrictions de circulation des
consommateurs et d'accès à certains
commerces en 2020 une douzaine d'acteurs
du Quick commerce sont implantés en
France en promettant une livraison de
courses alimentaires à domicile
généralement un moins de 15 minutes
rapidement ces startups ont levé
plusieurs millions d'euros on estime
qu'en 2021 les startups présentant en
France enlever 6 milliards d'euros
d'investissement c'est partir
régulièrement significatif dans un
contexte où les acteurs traditionnels du
secteur de la distribution subissent la
désaffection des investisseurs ces
acteurs traditionnels rejoint ce marché
afin de concurrencer ce qu'on appelle
les pure players certaines enseignes
historiques de la distribution est
investissent secteurs d'activités afin
de répondre à la demande croissante ce
virage stratégique a pour but de
répondre à la numérisation du commerce
mais également pour diversifier leur
circuit distribution et pour certaines
enceintes de permettre leur implantation
dans les centres-villes je pense
notamment à Carrefour ou à casino le
forêt du début marqué par une croissance
exponentielle et des investissements
majeurs et désormais largement retombée
et nous pouvons clairement analyser que
le Quick commerce est un marché de niche
il s'agit en France
d'un phénomène exclusivement urbain et
qui ne concerne essentiellement un
public de jeunes
de jeunes individus de 25 à 35 ans le
Quick commerce représenterait 12% des
achats alimentaires livrés à domicile en
2021 à l'échelle du pays et même 25% en
Île-de-France aujourd'hui le Quick
commerce génère un chiffre d'affaires à
ces modestes et représente une portion
infime du marché alimentaire en ligne
Paris sa petite couronne abrite 72% des
darks Store et 60% des Dark kitchen le
cadre réglementaire issu du décret de
l'arrêté publié le 22 mars 2023 dernier
entourant en vivre le 1er juillet ce qui
risque d'accélérer la décroissant de ce
secteur d'activité dont l'avenir était
déjà incertain en France
la récente demande de placement en
redressement judiciaire de la société
getir avec pour principale justification
le changement de réglementation et
particulièrement significatif les
auditions menées depuis plusieurs mois
ainsi que nos déplacements sur les lieux
d'implantation de darkshore et de Dark
kitchen ont mis en évidence l'existence
de nombreuses externalités négatives
induites par ces établissements tout
d'abord c'est dark Store et ses dark
kitchen causent d'un de nombreux cas des
troubles anormaux de voisinage les
installations de Quick commerce
s'implantent souvent dans des locaux ou
secteur qui ne sont pas adaptés à une
activité logistique le développement de
l'activité peut générer pour les
riverains des nuisances leur
implantation d'un des locaux bien
souvent inadaptés et sans déclaration
préalable cause des atteintes à la
tranquillité et à l'intégrité des
espaces communs du fait des
attroupements bruyants d'abandon de
déchets voire de dégradation
l'application des dispositifs issus du
décret signé récemment sera susceptible
d’améliorer significativement cette
situation cependant d'autres mesures qui
peuvent être mises en œuvre rapidement
peuvent également fluidifier les
relations entre les établissements de
Quick commerce et les riverains nous
avons notamment proposé d'imposer dans
les plus brefs délais aux opérateurs du
e-commerce l'inscription sur leur site
internet de mentions permettant un
contact direct par voie postale
téléphonique et électronique pour les
riverains les riverains pourraient ainsi
trouver des contacts utiles en cas de
nécessité le Quick commerce représente
également un coût social non négligeable
la population active du secteur du Quick
commerce singularise par l'importance
des prestataires indépendants notamment
chez les plateformes d'Olivier roux et
uber eat l'émission s'accomplisse
généralement sous le statut
d'auto-entrepreneur chez les livreurs
des plateformes travaillant sous le
statut d'auto-entrepreneur il ressort
des auditions qu'il y aurait jusqu'à 70%
de personnes étrangères en situation
irrégulière s'ajoute à cela un phénomène
de sous-location de compte les
plateformes qui s'estiment victimes de
ce genre de comportements ont mis en
place des dispositifs de vérification
d'identité recourant à l'intelligence
artificielle les principales plateformes
de livraison de repas ce sont engagées à
renforcer et à harmoniser les moyen de
contrôle de l'utilisation des comptes de
livreurs à titre d'exemple
uber eat nous a indiqué avoir procédé à
la désactivation de 2500 comptes à
l'issue de la campagne de vérification
des profils de livreur mais les efforts
entrepris apparaissent encore largement
insuffisants compte tenu de l'ampleur
des fraudes rien de garantit que ses
campagnes de contrôle se renouvellent
régulièrement et que les fraudes ne
réussissent pas les Cholet fraudeurs ne
réussissent pas à trouver de nouvelles
parades à ces dispositifs c'est pourquoi
madame la co-rapporteur et moi-même
avons proposé de renforcer les sanctions
pénales encourues par des personnes se
livrant à la sous-location de compte
dans le cas d'une activité de livraison
de produits alimentaires le travail
effectué par la mission ont également
confirmé la pharmacie de personnes
dépourvues de type de séjour parmi les
travailleurs du secteur du Quick
commerce pourtant la loi est claire et a
été rappelée lors de l'audition par le
représentant de la direction de
l'immigration le code du travail
interdit d'embaucher de conserver à son
service ou travailler pour quelques
durer que ce soit un étranger non muni
d'un titre l'autorisant à travailler en
France nous avons déterminé trois types
de fraudes tout d'abord une fraude
documentaire c'est à dire l'usage de
documents falsifié ou ne permettant pas
légalement le séjour sur le territoire
national d'autre part de trop grande
facilité pour obtenir le statut
d'auto-entrepreneur pour des personnes
qui ne remplissent pas les conditions de
régularité de séjour sur le territoire
national enfin la pratique de la
location des comptes évoqués
précédemment il apparaît clairement que
les plateformes malgré certaines
initiatives se montrent trop passives
face à ces frog massives nous avons donc
proposé de renforcer les sanctions à
l'encon des plateformes qui ont recours
à des personnes en situation
irrégulières il conviendra de préciser
les conditions de se renforcement des
sanctions comme pour d'autres secteurs
du commerce électronique la question
posée est celle de l'organisation des
services de livraison c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous estimons
indispensable de favoriser une meilleure
prise en compte du coût véritable des
livraisons du Quick commerce de notre
point de vue il s'agit d'organiser une
information du consommateur à propos du
coup réel et des répercussions de la
livraison à domicile et d'interdire la
position de la mention gratuit il
convient également d'évaluer la
pertinence de mon temps planché dans la
facturation des coûts de livraison au
consommateurs je souhaiterais conclure
un insistant sur l'avenir incertain du
Quick commerce en France et tout
particulièrement des Dark store la
plupart des acteurs du marché se sont
retirés du marché français pour ne
laisser qu'un duo pôle composé de la
société getir et de la société flink
nous avons également assisté à une
multiplication des rachats et des
fusions absorption entre opérateurs les
investissements réalisés dans le secteur
ont connu un ralentissement très
important entre 2021 et 2023 qui c'est
notamment concrétisé par une réduction
importante des effectifs de salariés
comme il est indiqué dans le rapport il
est encore trop tôt pour savoir s'il
s'agit de scènes difficultés
conjoncturelle ou de l'absence de
viabilité à long terme de ce modèle
économique cependant plusieurs personnes
auditionnées ont formulé d'importantes
réserves sur la viabilité économique à
long terme du Quick commerce le cours
relatif des services de livraison
représente sans doute le poste de
dépenses le plus susceptible d'opérer
les résultats financiers des entreprises
du secteur la livraison à Paris en effet
structurellement comme une activité à
perte l'avenir du Quick commerce en
France semble pour le moins incertain
mais les exemples venus de l'étranger
ont démontré la grande capacité de ses
acteurs à s'adapter aux nouvelles
réglementations et aux restrictions par
exemple à New York la société getir a
fait le choix d'ouvrir ses magasins aux
clients pour échapper à l'interdiction
municipale il ne faut donc pas
sous-estimer la capacité de résilience
de ces nouveaux acteurs du commerce il
faudra donc rester vitré vigilant aux
conditions d'application des textes
réglementaires récemment adoptés je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup madame salatini allez-y
madame la rapporteur malencatel
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
merci de votre accueil alors vous le
rappeliez si l'activité si l'actualité
toute récente révèle une vraie
difficulté quant au business model de
ces dark store ça ne signifie pas que le
Quick commerce en tant que tel
serait menacé compte tenu de
l'hétérogénéité des différents acteurs
qui recouvrent justement ces ce nouveau
mode de consommation et qui vont bien
au-delà de ces simples pures player des
Dark store alors nous ne considérons pas
qu'il faille sans remettre à la main
visible du marché pour décider du sort
du Quick commerce et nous estimons au
contraire qu'il revient la puissance
publique de faire prévaloir des intérêts
supérieurs et je pense ici au pluralisme
de l'offre commerciale à l'égalité
devant la loi qui s'impose à tous les
opérateurs économiques ainsi qu'à la
préservation de l'équilibre des milieux
urbains il nous faut également garantir
les conditions d'une régulation
proportionnée et d'une intégration au
tissu économique et social et contribuer
à nos objectifs environnementaux
alors premier volet au plan normatif
l'encadrement du coup de commerce exige
de veiller à l'efficacité du droit
applicable au commerce en effet le Quick
commerce et la livraison express de
produits alimentaires à domicile se
définissent avant tout comme des
activités de vente à distance dès lors
l'ensemble des textes qui régissent le
secteur d'être d'activité doit
s'appliquer je fais ici notamment
référence au cadre protecteur de la
directive européenne du 25 octobre 2011
relative au droit des consommateurs les
activités du Quick commerce entre
également dans le champ d'application
des normes européennes qui régulent le
commerce électronique par ailleurs les
acteurs du Quick commerce doivent en
principe remplir toutes les obligations
qui incombent au commerce et selon les
cas au restaurant
parmi ceux-ci figure notamment les
normes sanitaires fondées sur le paquet
hygiène les prescriptions qui résultent
de la loi égalim ou encore le droit de
la consommation autrement dit il n'y a
pas de trou dans la raquette du reste
les activités du Quick commerce et de la
livraison à domicile ne semble pas faire
l'objet de signalement ou de plaindre
quand tu as des irrégularités
particulières c'est pourquoi la mission
de préconise pas la création de
sous-catégorie pour autant c'est tout
l'objet de cette mission il convient de
ne pas relâcher la vigilance de fait les
conditions d'exploitation sont assez
diverses d'où notre proposition numéro 9
de poursuivre et d'approfondir les
contrôles des activités du Quick
commerce initié par la DGCCRF
au-delà il importe qu'en pratique les
spécificités de la livraison express de
produits alimentaires ne prive pas de
portée les exigences établies dans
l'intérêt de la société
un exemple le problème de la vente à
distance de l'alcool endroit la vente de
boissons alcoolisées à distance ou par
Internet suppose l'obtention préalable
d'une licence adaptée et par ailleurs la
législation française consacre
l'interdiction d'offrir ou de vendre des
boissons alcoolisées aux mineurs or des
doutes peuvent être émis quant à la
capacité des acteurs du Quick commerce
d'assurer en pratique l'accomplissement
des obligations établies pour en
garantir le respect à savoir le contrôle
de l'identité du consommateur final
à bien des égards la mise en oeuvre des
prescriptions de la Loi Ajac peut
susciter des inquiétudes similaires en
effet rien ne garantit que les services
de livraison de produits alimentaires
prennent des dispositions pour limiter
le gaspillage alimentaire et favoriser
une consommation respectueuse de
l'environnement il en va en ce qui
concerne l'utilisation des produits
alimentaires invendus ou de la
limitation de l'usage du plastique les
travaux de notre mission portent à
conclure que les initiatives prises par
les opérateurs résulte avant tout
d'engagement individuel et disparate de
fait plusieurs plateformes ont conclu le
15 février 2019 une charte d'engagement
qui vise à réduire l'impact
environnemental des emballages et
contenant utilisé par le secteur de la
restauration livrée pour autant
l'efficacité d'une telle démarche ne
paraît pas établie et les exigences de
la lutte contre le changement climatique
et de la préservation de l'environnement
justifie des mesures de caractères plus
normatif je tiens à rappeler quelques
chiffres 20% c'est la croissance qui a
enregistré la livraison de repas pendant
la crise sanitaire et dans les mois qui
ont suivi 600 millions c'est le nombre
d'emballages à usage unique généré pour
la livraison de 200 millions de repas en
2019 c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
préconisons d'inscrire dans la loi de
nouvelles mesures afin de conforter
l'utilisation des contenants alternatifs
réutilisables ou recyclables pour la
livraison de produits alimentaires au
terme de la proposition numéro 10 la
mission prône d'abord le développement
de la consigne en tirant les
enseignements des expérimentations
initiées en application de la charge du
15 février 2021 et dans la droite ligne
des travaux de notre collègue Philippe
bolaud nous appelons ensuite à la mise
en place d'un emballage standardisé aux
normes environnementales les plus élevés
pour la livraison à domicile de plats
préparés nous proposons de faire payer
le contenant des plats préparés de
garantir la collecte des anciens
contenants en organisant des circuits de
récupération par les livreurs ou de
dépôts par les consommateurs il s'agit
là d'une exigence de justice à l'égard
des physique qui sont eux soumis à ces
obligations mais aussi d'efficacité dans
la lutte contre la pollution plastique
deuxième volet la régulation du Quick
commerce implique d'affermir les
conditions d'application du droit social
et du droit du travail face aux
spécificités d'une économie flexibilité
et dématérialisée de fait les salariés
des établissements du Quick commerce et
les livreurs forment une population
active extrêmement précaire et par
ailleurs très peu féminisé il s'agit
d'actifs jeunes dont c'est la plupart du
temps la première expérience avec dotée
d'un diplôme inférieur au baccalauréat
et les postes exercés dans le secteur du
coût de commerce souvent sont pour eux
l'objet d'une première expérience
professionnelle alors sur le plan des
conditions de travail et de l'ordre
public la situation des travailleurs de
la livraison express de produits
alimentaires soulèvent au moins trois
questions fondamentales
d'abord la pratique du travail
dominicale en effet les entreprises du
Quick commerce opère non seulement sur
des plages extrêmement étendues en
semaine mais également le dimanche or
rien assure que la poursuite du service
répond à des nécessités en rapport avec
les exemptions prévus par le code du
travail je rappelle que la loi n'admet
le maintien d'une activité le dimanche
que sous réserve de motifs relativement
circonscrits à savoir les contraintes de
production de l'activité ou des besoins
du public
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
considérons comme extrêmement important
que les pouvoirs publics et l'inspection
du travail prennent les mesures
nécessaires au respect du repos
dominical dans un souci d'intégrité de
notre droit social et d'égalité de la
concurrence la deuxième question qui est
posée au service de livraison express
concerne la perception de situation
irrégulière à commencer par la présence
massive de personnes dépourvues de
titres de séjour d'après les estimations
de certaines organisations syndicales
ces dernières pourraient représenter
jusqu'à 70% des effectifs employés trois
facteurs peuvent expliquer ce chiffre
extrêmement important d'abord le
l'importance de la fraude documentaire
celle-ci se matérialise par l'usage de
documents falsifié ou de documents qui
ne permettent pas en réalité le travail
légal sur notre territoire on peut
également citer les conditions d'accès
aux statut d'entre d'auto-entrepreneur
ainsi que la pratique de la location de
compte de livreur contre ces pratiques
frauduleuses les plateformes de
livraison ont certes pris des initiative
par exemple en recourant à des
dispositifs techniques sont ces détecter
les documents falsifiés ou utiliser de
manière frauduleuse mais il nous
considérons que il faut signal qui
rappelle à l'ensemble des acteurs leur
responsabilités c'est pourquoi nous
prenons pour un renforcement des
sanctions à l'encontre des plateformes
qui emploie des personnes en situation
illégale afin de les inciter à donner
toute la portée nécessaire à leur
contrôle à titre personnel j'estime que
la lutte contre cette forme de travail
illégal ne saurait reposer sur des
mesures uniquement répressives avec
pragmatisme il nous faudra régler la
question du sort des livreurs
indépendants arriver sur le territoire
sans titre de séjour mais dont la
situation et le comportement présente
aujourd'hui toutes les garanties de
l'intégration aussi je plaide pour une
révision de la circulaire Valls afin de
permettre l'examen au cas par cas des
demandes d'admission exceptionnelles au
séjour pour les livreurs indépendants du
Quick commerce et du secteur de la
livraison
la lutte contre le travail illégal dans
le secteur exige encore de tarir les
sources d'une pratique porteuse de
précarité pour de nombreux travailleurs
indépendants je veux parler d'usurpation
des comptes attribués au livreur des
opérateurs de commerce et des
plateformes elle présente les mêmes
causes à savoir la falsification des
titres d'identité c'est la raison pour
laquelle comme le rappeler madame la
Cora porteur nous estimons qu'il
conviendrait de renforcer les sanctions
pénales à l'encontre des personnes qui
se livrent à la sous-location de compte
le dernier enjeu qui doit être traité et
celui de la capacité du secteur à
réduire par le dialogue social les
disparités qui peuvent séparer les
différentes catégories sur le plan des
conditions de travail et du partage de
la valeur la question se pose avant tout
pour les livreurs qui possèdent souvent
le statut d'indépendant et qui par
conséquent demeure tributaires des
rapports contractuels noués avec les
donneurs d'ordre les travailleurs
indépendants des plateformes disposent
depuis la loi el khomri d'un cadre de
représentation et de négociation
collective avec les plateformes
en lien avec l'ARPE dont l'émission
consiste à réguler à susciter à
accompagner le dialogue social entre les
plateformes de mobilité et les
travailleurs indépendants qui lui sont
liés par un contrat commercial il s'agit
là d'une exception française qui semble
de nature à permettre des avancées pour
les livreurs ainsi que la démontrer les
deux accords conclus le 20 avril dernier
ces derniers comportent trois principaux
engagements que je voulais vous rappeler
l'instauration d'un revenu minimal
garanti à hauteur de 11 euros 75 minimum
par heure de travail affective mais qui
ne prend pas en compte le temps
d'attente des livreurs deuxièmement
l'encadrement des déconnexions des
livreurs par les plateformes et
troisièmement un cadre méthode un cadre
de méthode pardon pour les conduites des
négociations futures
même s'ils demandent à être concrétisé
ses premiers engagements militants en
faveur d'un renforcement du cadre de
représentation et de la négociation
entre indépendant et plateformes c'est
dans cette optique que nous appelons à
stimuler les discussions et à veiller à
la pertinence des critères d'éligibilité
des organisations représentatives par
ailleurs il paraît indispensable de
lever les obstacles que peuvent créer
les statuts dans l'exercice des droits
et garantis au travail à l'évidence un
premières un premier facteur d'inégalité
réside dans la diversité des conventions
collectives qui couvrent la population
active du secteur aujourd'hui on en
dénombre 3 la convention collective du
commerce à distance la convention
collective des transports routiers ou
encore la convention collective
nationale des entreprises de la
logistique au-delà du critère de
l'activité principale leur attachement à
l'une de ces trois conventions demeures
fondamentalement à la discrétion des
entreprises et évidemment ça favorise
les disparités qui n'ont pas de raison
d'être
aussi nous estimons qu'il faut
travailler à l'établissement d'une
convention collective unique pour le
commerce de livraison de produits
alimentaires à domicile à défaut il faut
réaliser une clarification des clauses
de la convention du commerce à distance
et de la convention du transport
susceptible de régir cette activité
second facteur d'inégalité il réside
dans la précarité même du statut de
travailleurs indépendant la
qualification juridique de la relation
de travail entre les plateformes et les
travailleurs indépendants peu ainsi
soulever des difficultés du point de vue
de la reconnaissance des droits en
pratique la question posée est celle
d'un rapprochement et que les droits et
les garanties du salariat dans une
certaine mesure la jurisprudence de la
Cour de cassation illustrée par l'arrêt
du 4 mars 2020 ouvre de nouvelles
perspectives elle permet une
requalification de l'activité en contrat
de travail sont pour autant établir
nécessairement une présomption de
salariat du reste la question du statut
des travailleurs indépendants prend
aujourd'hui un nouveau relief avec un
projet directif de la part de la
Commission européenne à la suite du
travail qui a été réalisé au Parlement
européen et qui envisage l'établissement
d'une présomption de salariat des
travailleurs européens de notre point de
vue l'assimilation à la condition de
salariat ne peut être considérée comme
la seule voie possible certains
indépendants manifestent un réel
attachement pour leur statut et un
rapprochement des droits dont peuvent
bénéficier les salariés peut-être
réalisé par d'autres moyens c'est dans
cette optique que nous proposons de
garantir des droits des livreurs
indépendants par le recours à des
dispositifs de portage salarial
troisième et dernier volet l'intégration
du Quick commerce suppose d'assurer
l'efficacité des instruments développés
en droit de l'urbanisme il s'agit
d'abord de préserver la physionomie et
l'équilibre des paysages urbains face à
des entreprises qui dans leur quête
effrénées de croissance sont négligés
les conditions de leur insertion dans
des zones d'ensément peuplées cette
politique a pu conduire à l'aménagement
de locaux aveugles qui ne contribue pas
à l'animation commerciale des quartiers
ou encore à des installations dans des
lieux inappropriés une telle situation
mais d'abord en cause la pertinence de
l'environnement réglementaire applicable
à l'implantation des établissements du
Quick commerce alors cela ne signifie
pas que les documents de planification
urbaine ne comprennent pas des
prescriptions adéquates ainsi le PLU de
Paris affirme un certain nombre de
principes relatifs à la définition des
locaux relevant de la catégorie des
commerces au caractéristiques des
devantures aux conditions d'exploitation
des activités logistiques mais le
véritable problème portait sur le
classement des établissements du coup de
commerce dans les catégories prévues en
droit de l'urbanisme
le décret et l'arrêté qui ont été pris
clarifie un certain nombre de choses
et ces deux textes permettront de
clarifier le statut des établissements
du coup de commerce au regard de la
nomenclature des destinations existantes
dans cette optique l'arrêtait apporte
trois précisions fondamentales d'une
part il rattachent les Dark Store à la
sous destination entrepôt d'autre part
il crée une sous-destination propre au
dark kitchen et enfin il affirme le
caractère commercial des drive piétons
on les incluant dans le champ de la
sous-destination artisanat et commerce
de détails le nouveau cadre permet
également d'imposer une procédure de
déclaration préalable en cas de
transformation d'un commerce relevant de
la destination commerce et autres
activités de service en Dark Store ou en
Dark kitchen comme le souligne le
rapport les dispositions de l'arrêté du
22 mars 2023 ne valent que pour l'avenir
c'est pourquoi nous préconisons une
révision des plans locaux d'urbanisme
afin de tirer pleinement partie des
outils procurés par la définition des
catégories auxquelles se rattachent les
établissements du Quick commerce
outre la précision des normes il importe
de conforter la capacité des
collectivités à imposer le respect des
exigences des documents d'urbanisme de
fait les travaux de la mission ont tendu
à montrer les limites que peuvent
comporter la mise en oeuvre des droits
de préemption et l'exercice des pouvoirs
de police reconnu au maire et aux
présidents de PCI dans l'ensemble
l'intérêt de tels outils peut être
réduit par des délais procédureaux longs
ou les moyens que leur usage suppose
aussi deux voix nous semble pouvoir être
explorées première voie elle
consisterait à favoriser un plus grand
retour aux prononcé d'astreinte et
d'amandes administratives dans le cadre
du dispositif établi par la loi 2019 sur
l'engagement local en l'état ce dernier
patient d'un déficit de notoriété ainsi
que de la relative modestie des
sanctions pouvant être infligées c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous proposons
de relever le menton des amandes pouvant
être infligées et de mener une campagne
d'information sur le dispositif la
deuxième pourrait conduire à envisager
une décentralisation et une
dépénalisation des sanctions des
infractions au droit de l'urbanisme
n'entendons pas évidemment minorer les
enjeux que peuvent entourer
l'application d'une telle mesure mais
chacun pourra convenir que de telles
phénomènes disruptifs rendent malaisés
une réponse rapide à l'échelle nationale
compte tenu du caractère encore très
centralisé de notre état au-delà la
régulation du Quick commerce ne serait
dispenser l'État et les collectivités
d'une réflexion plus fondamentale sur
l'organisation de la logistique urbaine
cette question constitue désormais un
objet politique publique et a pu donner
lieu à quelques initiatives dès lors il
importe d'inscrire le développement du
Quick commerce dans le cadre des
initiatives tendant à l'aménagement
d'espace de logistique urbaine adapter
un approvisionnement des villes
conformes aux exigences de la transition
écologique
je ne peux je ne peux achever ce premier
exposé sans s'en remercier notre
administrateur John qui nous a
accompagné depuis six mois dans la tenue
de cette mission d'information au cours
de laquelle nous avons auditionné 87
acteurs en lien avec le Quick commerce
et la livraison express de produits et
bien alimentaires à domicile et je
voulais vous remercier monsieur le
Président de votre accueil
merci beaucoup mesdames les rapporteurs
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
aux orateurs des groupes politiques
alors le principe vous le connaissez
c'est 4 minutes par orateur réponse
incluse donc je vous laisserai vous
répartir les réponses que vous faites au
collègue et pour nos collègues donc
c'est deux à trois minutes
d'intervention pour vous laisser un
minima une minute de réponse si vous le
souhaitez nous commençons tout de suite
avec Nicolas Paco du groupe Renaissance
c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
rapporteurs chers collègues ce rapport
dont j'ai pris plaisir à lire ce contenu
et pour lequel je tiens à vous féliciter
mais en avant les spécificités du Quick
commerce c'est-à-dire simplifiant le
trait des plateformes proposant des
livraisons en ligne à toute heure et
dans des délais restreints ces
plateformes ont fait leur apparition
très récemment en France puisqu'elles
ont connu un véritable essor qui est que
la crise du covid-19
ce sont pour ainsi dire les dernières
arrivantes sur le marché de la
distribution alimentaire ce qui a
évidemment des impacts sur ce marché des
articles de presse récents montrent
toutefois la fragilité du modèle et son
avenir très incertain dans un contexte
de liquidation disparition ou de fusion
des principaux acteurs depuis quelques
mois de licenciement de salariés le
monde titré d'ailleurs hier l'économie
aura mis fin au Quick commerce plus vite
que la loi
néanmoins mais deux questions porteront
sur la concurrence entre les commerces
physiques traditionnels et les enseigne
de Quick commerce tout d'abord le
développement du coût de commerce a-t-il
entraîné une baisse des parts de marché
sur les segments traditionnels du
secteur c'est-à-dire les commerces
physiques si oui c'était fait est-il
plus visible dans les communes où les
commerces sont tendance à fermer plutôt
et à ne pas ouvrir le dimanche
deuxièmement les Quick commerce
respectent-ils les obligations légales
auxquelles sont soumis les distributeurs
traditionnels et je pense notamment à
l'encadrement des promotions merci
merci alors qu'il souhaite répondre
vous n'êtes pas obligé d'ailleurs c'est
comme vous le souhaitez
oui juste quelques mots par rapport à la
concurrence donc il ressort du rapport
qu'on n'a pas de chiffres provenants des
montrant qu'il y a une diminution du
chiffre d'affaires des commerces
physiques puisque le panier moyen
environ de livraison par le Quick
commerce à peu près 20 euros donc il y a
pas forcément d'arbitrage à faire
lorsqu'on est un consommateur puisqu'on
va sûrement faire d'autres achats au
prix de commerce dit plus classique en
revanche comparer notamment aux
promotions donc il y a des règles
applicables notamment avec la loi egalim
avec l'encadrement des offres
promotionnelles donc vous avez tout un
panel dans le rapport qui indique en
fait toutes les réglementations
applicables dans la loi Gallim fait
partie en revanche la il y a une
concurrence un peu plus diffuse sur tout
ce qui touche au dark kitchen parce
qu'en fait depuis le covid on peut voir
qu'il y a un repli sur la sphère un
petit peu plus domestique donc des
personnes qui ont recours à ces dark
kitchen vont pas forcément aller au
restaurant et on est aussi dans une
situation
où l'inflation est galopante donc après
c'est en fonction du pouvoir d'achat du
consommateur est-ce qu'il va vraiment se
déplacer dans un restaurant et ensuite
vous le verrez également dans le rapport
on touche un mot notamment par rapport à
la concurrence entre les restaurants
qu'on a possibilité de vendre leurs
produits via les plateformes mais dans
les l'algorithme le classement des
restaurants n'est pas forcément très
transparent donc c'est pour ça qu'on
propose une plus grande transparent une
de plus grande transparence dans ce
domaine
merci Madame Gatel allez-y vous avez une
minute oui juste pour pour rebondir les
Dark Store et la situation des Dark
store aujourd'hui
ce ne doit pas être l'arbre qui cache la
forêt du Quick commerce le Quick
commerce ça va bien au-delà des soldes
store on parle effectivement des Dark
kitchen on parle des plateformes et plus
généralement on parle d'un écosystème
autour effectivement des plateformes
mais qui concernent à la fois la grande
distribution puisque de nombreux
distributeurs passent par des
plateformes
uber eats ou des livres ou pour faire
leur livraison de courses alimentaires
et les restaurants traditionnels mais
aussi des chaînes de restauration rapide
passent également par les plateformes
donc en fait on est vraiment dans un
système d'interdépendance et non nous ne
sommes pas trop en retard pour légiférer
sur un sur un phénomène qui va encore
une fois bien au-delà du des seules
pures player des sols purs player du
Dark des Dark Store et effectivement on
est dans un système d'interdépendance
c'est-à-dire que les castors vont
concurrencer des des supermarchés de
quartier ou des épiceries de quartier
mais les Dark kitchen sont aussi dans un
système d'interdépendance avec les
plateformes merci beaucoup je vous
propose de passer ailleurs ménage du
groupe rassemblement national c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les rapporteurs chers collègues
le rassemblement national souscrit aux
objectifs de cette mission d'information
sur le Quick commerce cette mission
entre en résonance avec la commission
d'enquête relative aux révélations des
uber files et ses conséquences sociales
économiques et environnementales du
développement du modèle
uber en France votre rapport ne
dissimule pas que ce type de commerce
adossait un modèle économique fragile
pose de nombreux de nombreux problèmes
outre les problèmes relatifs à la
concurrence de cette activité par
rapport aux activités presque similaires
de proximité et se poser par leurs
conséquences sur l'environnement
urbain l'un des problèmes principaux et
social et économique
en effet les entreprises de Quick
commerce sont irrespectueuses des
obligations légales quant au statut des
personnes employées ce qui rend leurs
conditions de vie particulièrement
précaires notamment en l'absence de
protection de leurs droits sociaux
cette population est majoritairement
jeune masculine et très peu qualifiée
une part massive des personnels du Quick
commerce et de la livraison de produits
alimentaires sont dans des situations
irrégulières du point de vue du respect
de la loi et de leur protection sociale
on constate aussi la part très
majoritaire de personnes dépourvues
dépourvues de titres de séjour jusqu'à
70% des employés selon les entreprises
de ce point de vue il est regrettable
que des filières de trafic d'êtres
humains profit de cette opportunité
créée par le développement de ce modèle
économique douteux plus destiné à servir
les personnes aisées des grands centres
urbains qu'à offrir des opportunités
professionnelles digne à des populations
déjà fragilisées par leurs conditions
d'existence ce type de commerce favorise
aujourd'hui le recours à une main
d'oeuvre maltraité mal adapté peut voir
pas intégrer les fraudes au titre de
séjour et à la protection sociale
notamment ne font pas l'objet de
contrôle sérieux tant de
l'administration que des employeurs et
font ainsi prospérer des activités quasi
criminelles parallèles qui se greffent
mécaniquement sur une pratique pour le
moins opaque
il est il est dès lors indispensable
d'envisager des mesures destinées à
faire rentrer le Quick commerce dans les
faits dans le respect strict des lois
qui régissent l'emploi en France ce
secteur est assurément à mettre en
conformité effective avec l'application
du droit social et le rassemblement
national ne saurait se satisfaire de
quelques mesures qui manifesteraient par
exemple à la faveur d'une régularisation
massive de personnes contrevenant au
droit à une prime à la fraude les
rapporteurs peuvent-ils nous dire si
quelques pistes de bon sens pourraient
être appliquées l'application de la loi
en matière de séjour sur le territoire
national le renforcement des contrôles
de la part de l'administration et des
employeurs le renforcement de la loi
lorsque le défaut d'obligation des
employés en matière de vérification des
conditions d'emploi des personnes et
constatées merci
merci alors qu'il souhaite répondre
madame
oui quels éléments puisqu'il ressort du
rapport que vos 70 % des des
travailleurs sur les plateformes sont en
situation irrégulière donc certes il y a
un contrôle qui doit être fait puisqu'on
ne peut pas légalement embaucher
quelqu'un sur régulière puisque un
employeur est dans l'obligation de se
renseigner sur la nationalité de du
travailleur et s'il n'a pas la
nationalité française alors on doit
avoir une autorisation de travail pour
avoir un titre de séjour en conséquence
donc aujourd'hui il existe un titre de
séjour qui peut être
donné en fait pour des travailleurs pour
des travailleurs temporaires le travail
salarié mais la difficulté c'est que sur
ces plateformes en fait il y a
énormément voire quasiment que des
livreurs avec le statut indépendant donc
aujourd'hui la circulaire Weiss de 2012
n'est pas en mesure en fait de traiter
vraiment ce cas spécifique donc
aujourd'hui en fait le 4 règlementaire
c'est plus je crois qu'il a eu une
signature de charte d'ailleurs où les
plateformes s'oblige et se disent
d'ailleurs les premières victimes en
fait de cette situation
donc elle s'oblige à faire des contrôles
et elle indique en fait avoir recours
notamment à l'intelligence artificielle
et aussi avoir recours à des entreprises
extérieures notamment privées pour
vérifier la la véracité des documents
d'identité puisqu'en fait la une des
premières difficultés ce sont des
documents en général d'identité qui sont
falsifiés et ensuite il y a des
problèmes des sous-contins puisque
généralement ces livreurs sans papier
utilisent des comptes qui sont déjà
donnés à une autre personne et en fait
il y a un système de de reversement de
20 à 30% du chiffre d'affaires à cette
personne lorsque le compte est utilisé à
cette fin donc il y a voilà un vrai
travail qui est qui est fait sur cela et
notamment les contrôles en tout cas
c'est ce que les plateformes nous ont
dit c'est qu'elle se peintre sur
l'identification de connexion
particulièrement longue si une carte de
crédit et finalement attache à plusieurs
comptes donc ça pourrait être des
indices en fait qui laissera à penser
que ce sont des des travailleurs en fait
qui n'ont pas l'obligation qui n'ont pas
l'aut orisation de travailler dans ces
conditions
merci pardon j'ai vraiment j'ai dérapé
sur le calendrier excusez-moi madame
Simonet groupe LFI
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
rapporteurs je remercie les rapporteurs
pour ce travail et j'ai d'ailleurs
assisté à plusieurs auditions
passionnantes votre rapport très d'un
phénomène extrêmement néfaste un
véritablement plaie qui atteint nos
villes le Quick commerce parce qu'il est
antisocial il repose sur un modèle du
livreur travailleur surexploité souvent
sans papiers sans indemnisation en cas
d'incident du travail au très faible
droit en termes de sécurité sociale et
retraite son droit au chômage et c'est
également un modèle anti-écologique
parce qu'il encourage le consumérisme
immédiat et aveugle démultiplinant les
déplacements
inutiles et polluants et contribue enfin
détruire la vie économique des villes où
il s'installe en multipliant les façades
aveugles et en concurrence en de manière
déloyale le petit commerce or ce
phénomène du bérisations le pouvoir
macroniste ne cesse de le soutenir c'est
ce que nous démons d'ailleurs la
commission d'enquête en cours dont je
suis la rapporteuse sur les uber files
et cette mission et bien c'est bien sur
la base d'un total du même ordre qu'elle
a été créée il faudrait le rappeler
parce que la première version du décret
sur les Dax Store et Dark kitchen doute
2022 était directement rédigé avec et
pour les plateformes du Quick commerce
en les considérant comme de simples
commerces ces plateformes ont son
sciemment hors la loi y compris des
plateformes type getir qui se vendent
d'être dans un modèle de de salariés
getir d'ailleurs qui est en redressement
judiciaire un licencié l'an dernier 800
salariés sans aucun plan social alors
que la loi impose un pseud et qu'il y a
au moins 10 licenciements en 30 jours je
rappelle que Getty a touché un million
200000 euros entre 2021 et 2022 vont-ils
rendre l'argent alors moi je vous le dis
il est vraiment temps de séparer les
lobbys et l'état de ne plus laisser à
des plateformes hors la loi le soin
d'écrire la loi alors heureusement une
mobilisation des liloko a contraint le
gouvernement à revoir sa copie et à
débouchés sur le décret de du 23 mars
dernier qui considère les Dax et Dark
kitchen comme des entrepôts donnant un
levier aux collectivités pour empêcher
des implantations néfastes nouvelles sur
leur territoire dans ce rapport vous
abordez également le statut des
travailleurs alors je souhaiterais
vraiment féliciter notre gatele et vous
dire à quel point je partage votre souci
de nécessité de régulariser les livreurs
sans papier et de modifier pour se faire
la circular Valls que le gouvernement
vous entendent et j'attends d'ailleurs
toujours la réponse à ma question écrite
de la part de monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur Darmanin à ce sujet par
contre concernant le statut social des
travailleurs des plateformes vous
préconisez la solution du portage
salarial et vous citez le rapport froid
je veux quand même vous rappeler que le
rap en foin a d'abord dit que l'évidence
serait de requalifiant salarié les
travailleurs des plateformes
conformément à la juriste prudence le
portage salarial est une solution de
protection sociale que pour les vrais
indépendants ce que les livreurs ne sont
pas le Parlement européen préconise
l'adoption d'une directive de
présomption de salariat et vous semblez
hélas pourquoi je l'avais dit en
question d'actualité au Gouvernement à
Monsieur du soft il faut un véritable
débat au Parlement concernant
alinéa 1 pour qu'on puisse débattre et
voter sur la position de la France voilà
votre proposition de dernière phrase
conjointe minorité présidentielle et RN
serait-elle donc de protéger les
plateformes au détriment des droits des
travailleurs merci alors en quelques
secondes une réponse madame Gatel en
quelques secondes et chère Daniel
Simonet merci beaucoup de votre question
mais je dois vous démentir cette mission
d'information elle est pas du tout liée
à un scandale lié à un pré projet décret
qui n'avait été en rien validé par la
ministre Olivier agrégoire mais parce
que j'avais porté une proposition de
résolution il y a désormais plus d'un an
sur cette même question et c'est un
sujet qui comme vous le savez me tient
particulièrement à coeur sur la question
du portage salarial c'est qu'on
considère effectivement qu'il y a une
petite partie une petite partie des
livreurs qui sont des vrais indépendants
et qui souhaitent conserver ce statut
tout en et nous considérons pour autant
qu'ils doivent prétendre à davantage de
droit d'où cette proposition du portage
salarial mais on mentionne également le
travail en cours de la Commission
européenne post le travail qui a été
fait par le Parlement européen porté par
ma collègue Sylvie Brunet merci beaucoup
je vous propose de passer à Monsieur
Jérôme Nury du groupe LR
oui merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
les rapporteurs votre mission mais bien
en lumière les limites voir les dégâts
que peut causer cette forme d'économie
baptisée quick commerce que ce soit en
termes sociales avec des salariés ou des
travailleurs précarisés dans des
conditions de travail souvent difficiles
mais les dégâts sont aussi indirects
notamment auprès du commerce de
proximité les prix cassés que l'on
retrouve dans ce type de commerce
concurrence de manière déloyale les
commerces classiques le Quick commerce
concerne surtout les grands centres
urbains essentiellement l'Île-de-France
mais il pouvait veiller à ce qu'il ne se
diffuse pas sur nos territoires ruraux
et nos villes moyennes
le meilleur moyen de limiter l'extension
de ces pratiques chère à la start-up
nation et aux adeptes de la
mondialisation heureuse c'est
d'accompagner nos commerçants avant
qu'il développe eux-mêmes des services
de livraison des Services de présence
sur le web des services de Click and
collect or nous manquons d'outils de la
part de l'État pour faire passer notre
commerce de proximité vers ces outils
les régions les conseils départementaux
et les intercommunalités mettent en
oeuvre des opérations collectives de
modernisation du commerce pour aider les
commerçants dans leurs investissements
or la suppression du FISAC opérer lors
du précédent quinquennat par la majorité
Renaissance prive ainsi nos territoires
de fonds d'État cela a été redoutable
car nos opérations collectives sont
aujourd'hui sous dotés
ne pensez donc vous pas qu'il serait
utile de faire renaître un fond dédié
type feac pour aider nos commerçants de
proximité à investir et à rendre les
mêmes services que le Quick commerce
afin également de gommer les distorsions
de concurrence en différentes activités
commerciales
merci Madame Gatel
alors juste pour rebondir rebondir
pardon sur sur ce que vous évoquez par
rapport au prix cassés des Dark store
alors je voudrais préciser comme comme
la répondu tout à l'heure madame lakawa
porteur que les Dark store respectent le
SRP respecte la loi Gallim l'un d'entre
eux l'un des deux acteurs restants
passent par une une centrale d'achat
puisqu'ils sont adossés à Carrefour
mais mais là où je vous rejoins sur un
point c'est qu'on a la question de la
livraison et la livraison qui est
souvent gratuite or et c'est aussi un
point qui est développé dans le cadre de
ce rapport c'est qu'on souhaite que la
livraison a un coût et on souhaite que
l'information soit donnée sur le réel
coup d'abord il a un coût parce que il
faut rémunérer et c'est le sens de notre
apport le mieux possible et livreur mais
il a aussi un coup à travers des
externalités négatives liées notamment à
la dimension environnementale et on sait
effectivement poser la question autour
de cette de ces expressions livraison
gratuite qui tendent finalement à faire
perdre de la valeur à toute la chaîne
puisque il n'y a pas de livraison
gratuite et on ça fait partie des
propositions que nous faisons sur
justement l'information au consommateur
pour que chacun sache ce qu'il paye
réellement et pour que ce il n'y ait
plus de mention de livraison gratuite
pour que le vrai coût soit donné et
qu'il n'y ait pas de perte de valeur à
tout à tous les niveaux de la chaîne
merci Madame Sabatini allez-y vous reste
un élément pour nuancer votre propos
parce que vous parlez de prix cassés
mais c'est pas vraiment des prix cassés
puisque en général enfin en tout cas
lors des auditions on a eu connaissance
en fait de la faible active du prix de
la livraison par les consommateurs donc
généralement le prix qui n'a pas
vraiment pour la livraison et répercuter
directement sur les produits donc on est
plus dans le cas de d'offre
promotionnelles que de finalement de
vente de produits à prix cassés
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Madame Louise Morel du groupe modem
c'est à vous merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les rapporteurs chers collègues
au nom du groupe démocrate je voudrais
saluer la qualité de votre travail sur
ce rapport sur un sujet qui préoccupe
beaucoup de nos concitoyens mais
également nos collectivités locales le
Quick commerce vous l'avez dit a pris de
l'ampleur durant la crise sanitaire il
est à l'origine aujourd'hui de nombreux
embarras dans les zones denses le
développement rapide des darkst store
des Dark kitchen provoque de fortes
gènes urbanistiques et sonores mais
également social je voudrais revenir
plus particulièrement sur les
problématiques sociales et plus
particulièrement sur les conditions de
travail des travailleurs des plateformes
on a commencé à avoir ce débat mais plus
précisément les conditions de travail
inhérentes à ce métier sont
particulièrement difficiles il faut le
rappeler travail en milieu urbain
physique parfois dangereux charge
parfois lourdes horaires décalés et ces
travailleurs sous statut indépendant ne
bénéficie ni d'une couverture sociale ni
n'en accompagnement financier d'ailleurs
de la part des plateformes pour
disposition d'un moyen de transport dans
ces conditions il apparaît que les
livreurs travaillent en moyenne entre 9
mois et un an maximum dans secteur dans
votre rapport vous indiquez que près de
70% d'entre eux sont dépourvus de titres
de séjour et face à leur impossibilité
de travailler légalement sur le
territoire ils sont souvent contraints
pour survivre d'utiliser le compte
professionnel qui peut leur sous louer
et c'est jusqu'à 100 euros par semaine
pour eux alors mesdames les rapporteurs
j'ai plusieurs questions comment
pouvons-nous limiter la sous-location de
comptes professionnels qui est d'une
certaine manière le mot est peut-être un
peu fort mais une nouvelle forme
d'esclavage moderne et par ailleurs ont
récemment un accord a été signé entre
les livreurs et les plateformes qui a
mis en place une rémunération minimale
garantie de 11,75 €
dénonce et vous venez de le rappeler que
le prix payé par les consommateurs pour
leur livraison ne correspond pas au coût
réel de la course alors que pensez-vous
de cet accord comment s'assurer que le
montant soit réellement respecté alors
qu'aujourd'hui nous en sommes
visiblement encore loin je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame Gatta allez-y
merci beaucoup
plusieurs plusieurs sujets abordés
effectivement vous avez tout à fait
raison la question de la sous-location
de compte s'apparente à la traite
d'êtres humains puisque ce sont des
personnes qui
sous couverts de rémunération ouvrent un
compte sur l'une des plateformes pour le
sous-louer à des personnes qui ne sont
pas en situation légale de travailler et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
appelons à ce qu'il y ait de véritables
sanctions sur sur ce type de pratique
qui sont absolument inadmissibles
ignoble et qui aujourd'hui finalement ne
sont peu connus et peu sanctionnés
sur votre deuxième question je le
rappelais effectivement il y a une
dizaine de jours un accord s'est fait
jour entre les représentants des
livreurs et les plateformes alors il
faut quand même rappeler que le cadre
des négociations et extrêmement récent
puisque les élections ont eu lieu très
très récemment sous l'égide de l'ARPE et
nous n'en sommes au début de ce dialogue
social qui doit qui doit se poursuivre
s'accélérer c'est un premier pas il y a
la question effectivement du montant
minimal de livraison mais comme je
l'indiquais on parle de livraison on
parle pas de temps d'attente donc en
réalité c'est 11 euros 75 ne signifie
pas que à l'heure que les livreurs
gagnent 0,75 et mais il y a un deuxième
volet dont on a moins parlé et qui est à
mon sens beaucoup plus important c'est
la question de la déconnexion et la
caractère contradictoire de des
déconnexions c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
les plateformes ont d'une certaine
manière tous les droits concernant les
déconnexions cet accord permet qu'il y
ait une véritable procédure
contradictoire pour faire en sorte que
les livreurs ne soient pas déconnectés
simplement sur le bon vouloir pardon les
livreurs ne soient pas déconnectés par
les plateformes sur le bon vouloir des
plateformes
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Monsieur Albertini du groupe horizon
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues à mon
tour de vous dire l'intérêt que j'ai eu
à la lecture de votre rapport
d'informations et de saluer votre
travail tant il est fouillé et complet
vous êtes attaqué un sujet qui concerne
particulièrement nos territoires urbains
qui est composé aux élus locaux de
nombreux difficultés de nombreuses
difficultés ces derniers mois les maires
sont désormais à l'aise pour débattre
des Dark store des Dark kitchen nouveau
secteur de l'activité de l'économie de
la flemme ce compte ce concept très
contemporain qui surf sur les nouvelles
habitudes de consommation du on veut
tout à toute heure et depuis son canapé
on pourrait croire que ces nouvelles
pratiques outre qu'elles abîment la
langue de Molière sont irrésistibles
s'impose à tous pourtant plus que de les
subir plus que de les accompagner il est
nécessaire de les réguler et sur ce
point et de ce point de vue votre
rapport d'information il est
propositions que vous formulez sont très
pertinentes le Quick commerce pose des
questions en matière de droit du travail
par l'ubérisation des contrats il pose
des questions en matière d'aménagement
du territoire par la création sous-mance
sauvage de zone de stockage il pose des
questions en matière de coude
environnementale par la multiplication
des pas trop déplacement enfin il pose
des questions en matière de qualité de
vie aussi bien pour les riverains que
pour les salariés et comme vous l'avez
prisé il y a quelques instants la
génération d'un volume de déchets
relativement considérable et donc une
question peut-être un peu provocante
mesdames le Quick commerce est-il pas un
rebours de nos engagements pour réduire
l'impact environnemental et promouvoir
une économie verte je vous remercie
merci alors qui répond allez-y madame
getaine alors question totalement
pertinente et je pense qu'on partage
qu'on partage absolument votre constat
sur cette tendance de consommation qui
est qui a explosé au moment du de la
pandémie qu'il nous faut
réguler au maximum et qui va très
clairement à l'encontre de nos
engagements environnementaux je le
rappelais la loi AGEC finalement ne
concerne que très très indirectement le
secteur de la livraison à domicile alors
que vous avez en même temps des
professionnels notamment de la
restauration rapide qui font des efforts
attendus et nécessaires
vous avez en parallèle l'explosion d'un
d'un secteur d'activité qui au contraire
joue sur sur la profusion des emballages
des plastiques et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on appelle vraiment à avancer
justement sur cette question d'être
extrêmement volontariste pour faire en
sorte qu'il y a une diminution maximale
du de la quantité de déchets puisque ce
phénomène de livraison de repas à
domicile ne va pas s'arrêter du jour au
lendemain et il nous faut donc vraiment
avancer donc à travers des des
contenants qui soient les les plus
exigeants sur le plan de la durabilité
développer la consigne aussi à travers
la mise en place d'une économie
circulaire des contenants et faire payer
le contenant au consommateur final parce
qu'à nouveau tout ça a un coût un coût
social un coup environnemental et il
faut que chacun soit conscient
merci c'est bon très bien nous passons
donc à Monsieur Charles Fournier du
groupe écologiste c'était vous merci
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
rapporteurs alors nous sommes là devant
le dernier avatar de l'ubérisation et à
travers ce qu'on appelle l'économie de
la flemme voilà ce qui en dit long sur
le sujet qu'il y a qu'il y a derrière et
donc derrière ça évidemment nous avons
un modèle très dépendant au travail
précaire au travailleur indépendant la
moitié des entrepôts sont en situation
irrégulières si on regarde le droit de
l'urbanisme et c'est le cas notamment à
Paris il propose des vitrines et des
devantures au pacifié qui abîment
l'esthétique de de nos villes un niveau
d'hygiène discutable le rapport nous
nous le confirme il y a pas voilà il y a
là aussi des sujets et puis c'est en
concurrence directe alors on peut fait
miser dire qu'on n'a pas de données
scientifiques sur la mise en concurrence
mais ça se rajoute à tout le reste de la
conc au commerce de nos coeurs de ville
et on voit bien l'effondrement qui peut
exister c'est souvent le en même temps
qui a régné c'est-à-dire en même temps
en autorise un côté et de l'autre et de
l'autre côté on est les grands
défenseurs du du commerce de coeur de
ville des nuisances occasionnées de
va-et-vient répéter de stationnement des
livreurs bref derrière tout ça il y a
aussi un modèle de société qui se joue
une le tout consommation des impacts
écologiques énormes une accélération de
cette logique là et tout le monde s'y
met d'ailleurs les grandes les grandes
enseignes comme Auchan Carrefour Casino
ont racheté certaines de certains de ces
acteurs et ce sont positionnés aussi là
dessus alors pour nous la liste est
longue et quand on a un rapport
d'information comme celui-ci on peut
attendre de taper fort pas simplement de
réguler trouver même c'est bien d'avoir
des emballages consignés c'est
extrêmement intéressant mais ça règle
pas le problème de fond le problème de
fond de ce modèle là comment on
s'attaque à ce modèle là moi j'ai pas
toutes les solutions mais au moins deux
questions pourquoi ne pas avoir ne pas
vous proposer que les maires aient le
pouvoir réel d'interdire et pas
simplement par l'artifice du fait que ça
soit considéré comme des entrepôts et
non pas du commerce est le pouvoir
d'interdire ce type de commerce sur
l'ensemble de leur territoire et puis
pourquoi ne pas aller plus loin sur la
question de la présomption de salariat
et dans le rapport vous évoquez vous
évoquez le portage comme vous l'avez dit
peut-être intéressant pour quelques-uns
mais que fait-on sur sur le reste et
là-dessus quelle est votre position vous
les deux rapports tort sur la
présomption de salariat parce que c'est
bien là aussi le scandale qu'il y a
derrière ce modèle
merci qui souhaite répondre
madame Gatel allez-y
merci
alors deux choses
première chose par rapport au pouvoir
réel des mers
d'ores et déjà avant même le décret et
l'arrêté pris par le gouvernement les
mères avaient tout à fait la possibilité
d'autoriser ou d'interdire
l'installation au regard de leur plu de
ces dark Store et ses dark kitchen
simplement et d'ailleurs c'est assez
intéressant on a vu que Lyon c'est saisi
tout à fait de ces possibilités
la municipalité de Lyon et beaucoup
moins à Paris et on a vu la situation
parisienne et on a considéré qu'il y
avait un manque de moyens ça n'était pas
le cas les moyens existaient ils ont été
renforcés et très utilement renforcés
par le décret et la réalité qui ont été
pris par par le gouvernement
mais aujourd'hui les les mères ont tous
les moyens entre leurs mains néanmoins
on propose dans ce rapport
de réfléchir à la à la décentralisation
et dépénalisation tout simplement parce
que ça ça engendre le code de
l'urbanisme engendre des procédures qui
sont longues puisque on parle de de
sujets qui relèvent du droit pénal sur
la question du la présomption de
salariat je pense avoir répondu tout à
l'heure il y a effectivement la question
du portage salarial il y a le sujet qui
est actuellement
à la Commission européenne autour d'un
projet de directive je voudrais juste
rappeler que le texte initial du
Parlement européen a été rédigé par ma
collègue
issue du Mouvement Démocrate Sylvie
Brunet donc je partage tout à fait ça sa
position
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Madame Marie-Noëlle Baptiste elle lui
groupe socialiste c'était vous merci
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
madame les rapporteurs pour votre
travail et puis on la restitution sur
cette question importante ou cette
tendance de consommation
qui est en forte progression notamment
depuis la crise covid qui m'appelle
trois questions
certaines ont déjà été évoqué au-delà de
sur l'impact environnemental notamment
au-delà de la question du coût de la
livraison que vous avez évoqué il y a
évidemment le coût environnemental
plus réel est-ce que vous avez évalué
cet impact environnemental et la
proportion d'utilisation de mode de
mobilité propre par rapport à la
mobilité traditionnelle sans compter la
question des emballages que vous avez
évoquée donc ma question c'est comment
imposer des pratiques vertueuses plutôt
que de encourager et d'issue dissuader
les pratiques polluantes donc au-delà de
ces encouragements est-ce que vous
envisagez
de proposer
une PPL ou des
aménagements législatifs qui peuvent qui
pourraient être beaucoup plus coercitif
sur la question de la concurrence avec
les petits commerces de proximité on
assiste évidemment une ubérisation des
centres-villes parce que la
réglementation vous paraît suffisante
mon collègue a évoqué la question des de
la possibilité donnée aux maires
évidemment aujourd'hui ils peuvent
davantage gérer les implantations mais
est-ce que cela est suffisant
sur la question des inégalités
territoriales qu'a évoqué mon collègue
Nury tout à l'heure sur les milieux
rural qui seront évidemment pas
forcément desservis par ce type de
commerce peut-être faut-il s'en réjouir
d'ailleurs et ma dernière question
sur les conditions de travail sur
lesquelles vous avez travaillé c'est un
sujet qui nous semble évidemment majeur
à sécuriser à la fois sur la question
des rémunérations qui sont bien loin
d'être à la hauteur du travail sur la
question de la pénibilité sur la
question de l'accidentologie puisque
beaucoup sont à vélo et avec des
conditions
de rapidité d'exécution qui les
entraînent assez régulièrement sur sur
des accidents voilà donc en clair est-ce
que votre travail va déboucher sur des
propositions législatives qui puissent
encadrer davantage sur les trois points
que je viens d'évoquer je vous remercie
merci qui souhaiterait répondre alors
oui juste à côté
de véhicule donc ça on l'a évoqué dans
le rapport donc il y a déjà un cadre
dyslatif qui existe puisqu'on a de la
loi à l'homme on a la loi climat et
résilience se faire de ma part sauf
qu'on est plutôt sur une obligation de
moyenne pas de résultats donc nous on
préconise déjà de durcir un petit peu
ses règles pour notamment obliger les
entreprises
aller vers un verdissement de leur faute
de véhicule de plus en plus important
concernant ensuite le salaire minimum
après je laisserai ma collègue répondre
sur le reste soit faire de ma part on a
également un accord qui a été qui a été
signé un avril 2023 par le biais de de
l'art
et en fait qui ma collègue l'a dit tout
à l'heure qui est encadre en fait les
les abus de déconnexion mais également
qui met en place un salaire minimum donc
ça c'est quand même pas à souligner
puisque un peu de temps il y a quand
même une évolution qui s'est faite
madame Gatel oui simplement sur le
verdissement le verdissement des flottes
effectivement il y a il y a un certain
quelque chose qui sont prévues par la
loi l'homme mais on se heurte à une
difficulté particulière vous avez d'un
côté les Dark stores qui font appel à
des livreurs qui sont salariés et pour
lesquels dans la plupart du temps à une
exception près vous avez des flottes qui
sont propres c'est à dire vélo
électrique scooter électrique évidemment
ça n'est pas le cas de tous les livreurs
indépendants qui ne sont pas aidés dans
l'achat de véhicules propres
dès lors il faut qu'on avance sur ce
sujet et notamment en et ça c'est une
proposition que je porte à titre
personnel sur de donner au pouvoir le
pouvoir aux collectivités territoriales
d'avancer dans le cadre des édefe merci
beaucoup je crois que tous les orateurs
groupes qu'il souhaitaient ont pu
s'exprimer très bien je vous propose de
passer aux questions individuelles j'en
ai pas beaucoup à ce stade mais
n'hésitez pas à lever la main si vous en
avez qu'on puisse vous noter une minute
par question on les prend toutes et
ensuite vous répondez d'une traite on
commence avec Monsieur Bouix
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
rapporteurs vous avez mentionné la
situation de la vente d'alcool et
l'absence de licence je voulais savoir
si vous aviez constaté d'autres
infractions à la réglementation je pense
notamment
à votre apport qui fait mention des
produits d'hygiène et plus
particulièrement des produits de santé
que ce soit du matériel médical ou des
médicaments et que ce soit
fait et réalisé soit par des acteurs
institutionnels du monde de la santé
soit par des acteurs non institutionnels
merci
bien nous continuons avec Madame
Grangier
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
rapporteurs merci beaucoup pour ce
rapport complet qui décrit une situation
très préoccupante à des facteurs de la
précarité des travailleurs exerçant dans
le secteur du Quick commerce tient au
statut de travailleurs indépendant car
ils sont en général en portage salarial
il existe pourtant de manière évidente
un lien de subordination entre les
plateformes et les livreurs les
plateformes du type deliveroo ou uber
eat fixe les niveaux de rémunération
supervisa distance les prestations et ne
permettent bien souvent pas au livreur
de choisir leurs horaires et de refuser
leur mission en effet dans la grande
majorité des cas ces plateformes
disposent de ce que l'on peut qualifier
d'autorité sur les livreurs ne serait-il
pas pertinent du coup de mettre en place
un système de présomption de salariat si
plusieurs des critères évoqués sont
remplis afin d'éviter un obstacle majeur
à la reconnaissance et à l'exercice des
droits sociaux et du droit du travail je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup nous passons à me suivent
oui merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
les rapporteurs les collectivités
territoriales et vous le savez sont en
première ligne face au risque que pose
l'émergence de ces nouvelles formes de
commerce comme le souligne très bien
votre rapport il demeure difficile
d'identifier un cadre juridique précis
permettant aux élus locaux de réguler ce
phénomène et de maintenir une diversité
commerciale le droit en vigueur prévoit
des procédures mais elle reste
insuffisamment efficace en 2022 le
gouvernement publié un guide sur les
règles applicables de cette nouvelle
entités notamment en matière de respect
des documents d'urbanisme aussi ce guide
est-il toujours opérant répond-il aux
attentes des collectivités territoriales
face aux enjeux de la gestion des sols
et de l'aménagement du territoire je
vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur Vegeta oui
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
rapporteurs merci pour ce rapport d'une
grande qualité une observation vous avez
mentionné et relevé dans votre rapport
le fait que ces sociétés les acteurs du
secteur se trouvent face à des à des
défis en termes notamment de financement
et il est vrai que ce sont des sociétés
qui immédiatement après le covid ont
attiré énormément de capital du fait de
l'attractivité de apparente de ce
nouveau business model mais depuis elles
ont subi un énorme reflux de la part de
l'intérêt en termes d'intérêt des
investisseurs et des fonds de vencher
capital notamment et d'ailleurs vous
l'avez souligné vous-même la plupart des
fonds levés sont désormais voués à la
consolidation du secteur rachat
d'acteurs en difficulté et étant donné
les tendances actuelles de la crise du
financement des startups et en
particulier de ces startups dont le
poste covid démontre qu'elles ne sont
pas forcément adaptées à une réalité des
besoins
nous trouvons face à une industrie qui
aura peut-être complètement disparu dans
les 12 prochains mois du coup quel est
votre d'avoir avez-vous analysé la
situation financière de ces entreprises
et avez-vous proposé une adaptation de
la travail législatif en fonction de du
calendrier de cette disparition merci
merci Madame Simonet
oui mesdames les rapporteurs vous n'avez
pas répondu à ma question concernant
l'origine de la première version du
décret sur les dator et Dark kitchen
quelles sont les plateformes qui ont
participé à l'écrire et comment se
fait-il que ce premier projet et bien
n'est pas fait l'objet d'un audition
contradictoire avec les élus locaux je
remercie
merci j'ai madame en grand merci
monsieur le Président merci mesdames
pour leur et les rapporteurs pour votre
travail vous avez les véhicule sujet la
vente des produits alcoolisés fait
partie de l'offre commerciale des
acteurs du Quick commerce selon
plusieurs personnes auditionnées la
vente d'alcool représenterait une part
significative du chiffre d'affaires des
entreprises du Quick du Quick commerce
il apparaît pourtant que la législation
interdisant la vente d'alcool au mineur
soit peu ou pas contrôlée quelle mesure
pour être envisagée pour garantir le
respect de la législation sur la vente
de la livraison et la livraison des
produits alcoolisés notamment pour les
mineurs merci
merci beaucoup j'ai monsieur Bothorel
merci monsieur le Président Madame les
rapporteurs merci pour la présentation
de ce rapport ce matin d'abord très
rapidement quand j'ai entendu monsieur
Nury tout à l'heure je peux pas laisser
passer que l'État aurait été absent dans
l'accompagnement des commerces à la
recherche de l'omnicanalité je veux
rappeler les investissements extrêmement
lourds qui ont été faits en 2020 en
soutien les collectivités d'ailleurs sur
la numérisation des commerces c'est bien
la banque des territoires qui étaient
aux côtés des collectivités et qui a
permis le déploiement d'un certain
nombre d'outils pour ces commerçants en
recherche de leurs clients au moment où
la crise covid était au plus dure je
voudrais savoir madame les rapporteurs
comment vous avez accueilli le rapport
de l'ADEME qui essaye de cerner le sujet
pour éviter les poncifs qu'on a pu
encore entendre ce matin sur le fait que
le e-commerce serait moins respectueux
de l'environnement que le commerce local
les choses sont beaucoup plus complexes
ainsi que le deal le rapport de l'ADEME
comment l'avez-vous accueilli comment
l'avez-vous intégré éventuellement à
votre sujet puisque le Quick commerce
n'est pas le e-commerce le e-commerce
n'est pas uniquement le prix de commerce
c'est un sujet effectivement extrêmement
important merci
merci beaucoup monsieur delépineau
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames pour la qualité de votre
travail vous évoquez dans votre rapport
l'ampleur des sous-déclarations des
revenus des auto-entrepreneurs
travaillant en lien avec des plateformes
de Quick commerce le phénomène est
considérable puisque le manque à gagner
généré par ses sous-déclarations
des cotisations du par ailleurs les
déclarations faites par les plateformes
elles-mêmes sont selon l'Observatoire du
travail dissimulé insuffisante dans un
contexte de sous-déclaration de la cible
pouvez-vous considérer que le recours au
dispositif contractuel du tir de
confiance que vous préconisez soit
suffisant pour inverser la tendance et
peut-on compter sur la seule bonne
volonté des opérateurs du secteur sans
consolider un bolet plus répressif je
vous remercie pour votre réponse
bien je n'ai pas noté de questions
additionnelles est-ce que quelqu'un
souhaitait intervenir alors j'ai allez-y
j'ai
allez-y allez-y
monsieur Tavel merci monsieur le
Président chers collègues madame les
rapporteurs merci pour ce rapport
éclairant le Quick commerce et la
livraison de produits alimentaires à
domicile soulève de nombreuses questions
parmi lesquelles les enjeux de RSE et
des co-responsabilités les entreprises
de Quick commerce doivent intégrer dans
leur modèle économique les enjeux
environnementaux c'est-à-dire les
émissions de carbone le recyclage ou
encore l'utilisation des énergies
renouvelables votre rapport indique
qu'en 2019 plus de 200 millions de repas
ont été livrés générant 600 millions
d'emballages
à l'usage unique et les exigences en
matière de lutte contre le changement
climatique nécessite la mise en place de
mesure normatives ma question est la
suivante mesdames les rapporteurs
comment inciter les entreprises de Quick
commerce à utiliser moins de plastique
et plus largement comment les inciter à
se verdir bien que vous ayez déjà
répondu sur le sujet avez-vous des
éléments à préciser merci
merci beaucoup on termine avec Monsieur
Tavel
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
rapporteurs madame Gatel vous avez dit
que il paraissait pertinent de
régulariser les salariés dans les
travailleurs sans papiers exploités par
ces plateformes sur quoi nous
souscrivons le débat sur la loi
immigration et repoussée on ne sait
quand c'est sans doute une bonne
nouvelle contenue de ce qui était prévu
dedans mais vous avez bien rappelé que
c'est une circulaire qui aujourd'hui
fixe les conditions de régularisation
par conséquent il n'est pas besoin de la
loi et le gouvernement a la possibilité
le ministre de l'Intérieur de prendre
une nouvelle circulaire dès demain matin
s'il le souhaite est-ce que vous avez eu
des échanges avec le ministre est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est quelque chose qui
peut être entendu par le ministre de
l'Intérieur et par le gouvernement dans
un délai beaucoup plus rapproché que les
potétiques discussions d'un projet de
loi sur l'immigration
bien plus de questions additionnelle
merci beaucoup bah écoutez mesdames les
rapporteurs je vous propose de répondre
comme vous le souhaitez comme vous le
sentez qui commence LMC oui tout d'abord
quelques mots concernant je crois que
c'était la question de Madame Engrand
sur la vente d'alcool donc évidemment on
ne peut pas vendre de l'alcool à une
personne mineure puisque sinon il faut
vérifier son état de minorité donc dans
le cas des plateformes c'est un peu plus
compliqué parce qu'on ne sait pas qui
qui consomme et qui a derrière en fait
l'application donc il y a un système qui
a été mis en place notamment pour
envoyer une notification auprès du
livreur qui sera susceptible de de
livrer une personne mineure et en ce
moment là il sera en mesure en fait de
vérifier son identité encore là de
nuances parce qu'il faut que le livreur
déjà prennent le temps de le faire dans
ce qui va avoir le temps de le faire
puisque le temps est très bref au niveau
entre le la commande et la livraison et
ensuite il n'y a pas vraiment de
contrôle effectif voir pour vérifier que
cette vérification soit effective
ensuite madame Simonet vous parlez je
crois de la première version mais après
j'ai envie de vous dire aujourd'hui ça
compte plus beaucoup puisque maintenant
c'est plutôt l'arrêté le décret qui vont
être appliqué donc je ne vois pas trop
la pertinence de votre question
concernant ensuite
la question de Madame Grangier par
rapport au travailleur indépendant donc
la présomption de salariat c'est pas
forcément qu'on est on n'est pas
forcément pour dans le sens que déjà
c'est le juge qui devra caractériser si
jamais il y a salariat ou pas on
préconise dans le rapport de de faire
bénéficier aux travailleurs indépendant
de certains nombre de protections
notamment la protection sociale le droit
au chômage etc via le système du Portal
salarial ensuite je pense que je vais
laisser ma collègue vous répondre sur
sur les autres sur les autres questions
bien allez-y madame Gatel
je voulais revenir sur l'intervention de
Monsieur Vegeta sur la sur le la
situation et le business model les
consolidations successives dans le
secteur des Dark store vraiment pour
insister sur un point c'est que les Dark
store ne doivent pas être là qui cachent
la forêt les darkstore c'est une toute
petite partie un tout petit élément de
de cette de ce nouveau mode de
consommation
fulgurant depuis la crise sanitaire mais
qui était qui était arrivé avant que ce
soit les plateformes de livraison ou des
acteurs comme frichti étaient
préexistant à la crise sanitaire
contrairement au dark Store qui
effectivement sont arrivés après la
crise sanitaire mais tous les sujets
qu'on évoque là le sujet de l'impact sur
la commercialité de nos villes sur
l'urbanisme commercial sur le modèle
social le modèle environnemental se pose
au-delà des darkstore vraiment les
darkstore je voudrais vraiment insister
là dessus ça n'est pas l'arbre ça ne
doit pas être l'arbre qui cache la forêt
parce que le le secteur entier la
livraison express de produits
alimentaires à domicile c'est c'est un
écosystème d'interdépendance vous avez
des restants de quartier des chaînes de
restauration rapide des des Dark kitchen
des Dark store des acteurs de la grande
distribution traditionnelle qui sont
dans cet écosystème aux côtés des
plateformes de livraison vous pouvez
vous faire livrer vos courses par uber
eats vos courses de n'importe quel
grandes marques comme vous pouvez faire
vous faire livrer vos plats préparés du
restaurant de quartier comme des chaînes
de restauration rapide via les
plateformes de livraison ce qui ce qui
pose et c'est pour ça que tous les
sujets qu'on a mis en avant ce matin
tant sur le volet social
qu'environnemental de distorsion de
concurrence doivent trouver une
expression
au delà de la pérennité ou non des
acteurs des Dark store donc je voulais
revenir sur sur quelques sujets
notamment sur sur le volet social
la question a été évoqué tout à l'heure
sur sur
les garanties les droits qui sont donnés
au livreur et qui sont d'autant plus
nécessaires qu'on est sur un modèle qui
est fondé sur la vitesse et donc la
vitesse ça signifie enjeu de sécurité
routière en jeu d'accident du travail et
aujourd'hui les livreurs qu'ils soient
salariés ou indépendants ne connaissent
pas leurs droits et n'ont pas
suffisamment accès à leurs droits et
c'est ce sur quoi il faut vraiment
travailler sur la question de la
présomption de salariat on y a répondu
il y a le sujet du portage salarial et
il y a en attendant le projet de la
Commission européenne voire comment
est-ce que ça pourra aboutir au niveau
de Bruxelles et comment ce sera
transposé dans notre droit sur la
question environnementale non
effectivement le coût de commerce ça
n'est pas le e-commerce et les enjeux
environnementaux ne sont pas ne sont pas
du même ordre on en a listé deux
principaux qui sont donc l'utilisation
du plastique des emballages et la
nécessité d'avancer sur cette question
et de faire en sorte que la loi AGEC
puisse irriguer aussi ce secteur de la
livraison à domicile et puis la question
du verdissement des flottes qui est
extrêmement important je voulais revenir
sur la question de l'alcool juste pour
préciser que ces organisations qu'il
s'agisse des restaurateurs des Dark
Storm ou des Dark kitchen ont ou en tout
cas on n'a pas d'informations
contradictoires les licences adaptées
c'est juste la question du contrôle par
le livreur dont on a conscience que en
réalité ça peut être fait comme ça peut
ne pas être fait et sur la question
migratoire c'est une position que je
défends à titre personnel mais je
considère effectivement que la
circulaire valse qui aujourd'hui ne
prend pas en considération les
indépendants pour des raisons qui se
justifient totalement qui sont
totalement encables ça n'est pas si
simple de prendre en considération
demain les indépendants ça pose par
ailleurs d'autres sujets et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il me semble-t-il
ça doit faire l'objet d'une discussion
plus large mais en tout cas c'est c'est
un aspect que j'appelle de mes vœux
merci beaucoup merci mesdames les
rapporteurs pour votre travail et la
réponse aux différentes questions que
nous avons eu ce matin je vais donc
soumettre vote de la commission
l'autorisation de publier le rapport
d'information qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient et bien donc nous
autorisons la publication du rapport
d'information je vous indique que les
prochaines réunions seront mardi 9 mai à
17h30 présentation du rapport
d'évaluation de la loi du 8 novembre
2019 relative à l'énergie et au climat
ce sera Madame baptistel et Monsieur
Lavergne qui nous présenterons ce
rapport et puis le mercredi 10 mai 9h30
15h et 21h30 on commencera l'examen de
la proposition de loi adoptée par le
Sénat après engagement de la procédure
accélérée visant à renforcer la
prévention de la lutte contre
l'intensification et l'extension du
risque incendie ce sera madame panonak
et monsieur l'amirault qui seront les
rapporteurs bonne journée chers
collègues